[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
This is Stephanie Wong,
and we are back today
with networking
specialist Ryan Przbyl.
You might recognize him from
our popular series, "Networking
101," "102," three,
four, and five, where
he covered Google
Cloud's networking
fundamentals with me.
And last time, he discussed
how enterprise networking
in the cloud is changing from
traditional to service-oriented
networking, a mentality
shift for companies and cloud
providers alike.
And today, we're covering how
you can approach these changes
and how Google
Cloud, specifically,
is addressing it and
evolving with it.
So before I start, I just want
to mention, please, please
comment below with questions.
Anything that we didn't
get to last time,
we are going to take
a look at all of them.
So definitely chat
us, and make sure
that we can get to
all of your questions.
And for Ryan, to
kick it right off,
last time, we talked
about customers
moving newer
applications to the cloud
and adopting service-oriented
networking functionalities.
So what do we provide
as a stepping stone
to enable enterprises who do
use this traditional networking
model?
RYAN PRZBYL: Yeah.
So I think Google is continuing
to evolve our networking layer
constructs, and I think all the
cloud providers are doing this.
And there's a lot of interesting
internal conversations
that I have with engineers
and product managers.
I think everybody wants to
work on the newest, latest,
greatest things.
And I'm constantly
having to remind people
that there's a lot
of fundamental stuff
that we still need
to work on as well.
And maybe it's not the bright,
shiny object, sexy thing
to work on, but it's very
critical for an enterprise.
The more products and tools
I can offer to replicate
your data center environment--
which I touched on last time--
the more of those
features I have,
the more you can pick and
choose how you want to migrate
and what stepping stones
you want to integrate.
So you could have like, "OK,
I'm going to move like this,
and it's going to be literally
a mirror image of my data
center--" and that assumes
we had every networking
product working everywhere you
wanted it, you could do that--
and then say, "After I migrate
to 10,000 applications,
I'm going to make this
change, and that's going
be my first stepping stone."
The reality is none
of the cloud providers
are completely there yet.
We're having to literally
re-engineer 50 years of telecom
into this cloud
environment, into the SDN,
and we're building all sorts
of products and features
that maybe have been
very traditional
for many, many years.
But the bottom line
is because we're
building all these constructs,
not necessarily from scratch,
but we have to build
all those features in.
So as an example, if you do
a lot of routing with, say,
communities and
local pref and things
like that at a routing
layer, that's not something
you could just bring
into Google Cloud
today and use a Cloud
Router to do that.
So that's a point of
function that isn't there
that we need to
continue to evolve.
And again, all cloud
providers are in this boat.
So in terms of those
stepping stones,
I want to be able to continue
to push Google and continue
to build all of
those tools that give
the customer those
stepping stones to say,
"I want to make these
little incremental changes."
The worst thing, the
worst thing I have to do
is get with the customer
and say, "You can't do it.
It has to be done this way,"
because as I mentioned before,
depending on what that
particular way is,
that could be a very
big chunk to bite off
and be very difficult for
the customer to adopt.
So I'm always cognizant
of that, and that's why--
again, coming with a very
traditional networking
background, I'm
always pushing us
to keep developing those
small stepping stones
that customers can place to
help them make that change.
Now, a good example of like--
let's say you were a traditional
network infrastructure setup,
and you wanted to, say,
start introducing some
of these service constructs.
So I talked about PSC, Private
Service Connect, before.
You could say, "I want
to use PSC to front-end
a particular Google
API, and I just
want to try it out that way."
Or maybe you're using
a cloud service.
Maybe you're using
something like Snowflake
or something else that's
really designed and grew up
in the cloud.
And that would be a
great place to introduce
some of these service layer
constructs into the model,
where you're not trying to all
of a sudden change everything,
but you're just saying, "I
want to front maybe the Google
APIs with a PSC endpoint."
Tons of customers use
Google APIs every day
to do all sorts of things.
That would be a
great stepping stone.
And then you get to
understand how does PSC work.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Just talking about
for the people who do want
visibility and control
over building something
like a NAT gateway
and handling
routing, what's been
the response from providers
like Google Cloud?
RYAN PRZBYL: Yeah.
So this goes back to
like, there's still things
that we are building.
So like when you take PSC
and it's being a managed
service, where
we're handling that
and we're handling
routing under the covers,
let's take the NAT case.
We understand that there's
still product development
work that we have to do
on that functionality,
and we are constantly evolving.
So this is what I'm referring
to when we talk about customers
aren't always comfortable
with losing that visibility,
but it's incumbent on
your cloud provider
to understand where
you're coming from
and why you're coming from
there and continue to evolve
their networking technology.
Now, that being said,
NATing is nothing new.
It is a very old
technology that's
been around for a long time.
It's just certain
levels of functionality
we have yet to develop.
So I think this is a key point.
We talked a little bit about--
I think most people agree
the service networking
model is the way forward.
If you look 20 years
from now, everybody
is going to be using
that paradigm, I think.
And it's easy to continue to
say, "That's the cutting edge
stuff.
Let's go and develop that
stuff," versus something,
say, like NATing that
is an old technology.
One approach is, "Oh, let
the customers manage it.
They can put their own
NAT gateways in there,"
or "They can do
things themselves,"
and there are ways
to do this stuff.
But we want to continue
to enable customers
with easy-to-use,
easy-to-consume services.
So like I said, we're doing
more work on the NAT front
to expand out capabilities.
So a customer who is maybe not
entirely comfortable using PSC
because they lose some
visibility things, we're
giving them more and more
of that network layer
functionality so that they can
build, again, what they have
in the data center to replicate
it as much as possible to give
them that comfort factor of
getting into cloud and then,
once they're in
cloud, start to look
at some these
other technologies.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And I do know that we have some
visibility and intelligence
options.
For example, we just came
out in the last couple
of years Network Intelligence
Center, which gives you
visibility for
things like running
connectivity test
between endpoints
or monitoring your
performance through Dashboard
or in looking at your topology
from a visual standpoint.
And so this seems like
it's more in the realm
of a service-oriented model,
but do you consider this
an overlapping area,
where we can start
to build bridges and allow
traditional networking
architects and
engineers to understand
how to get visibility in a
service-oriented environment?
RYAN PRZBYL: Yeah.
It's really interesting
because I've been in the space
for 20 years, and I
have touched I don't how
many thousands of networks, but
they're all built differently.
Nobody builds-- two networks
are like a fingerprint.
They're all slightly
different, and it's
our job to understand that.
But one fundamental is being
able to troubleshoot them
when they break.
And as I mentioned earlier,
when you move into the cloud
and you move into
our SDN and how
things have been
built under the hood,
that isn't always easily
understandable by customers.
So tools like Network
Intelligence Center
are designed to help
bridge that gap.
You may have a very
traditional way
of troubleshooting your
network and saying, "OK, I
can see all these paths."
But things like a
traceroute, for example,
which is a very common
troubleshooting tool--
it doesn't always give
you the information
that maybe it would in your data
center where you can see like,
"OK, I'm hopping here.
I'm hopping here.
I'm hopping into a firewall.
I'm going through the firewall.
I'm hopping to another router."
You don't typically get
that kind of information.
So just as an example,
when you build a VM,
we program route
tables onto that VM.
We program firewall
rules on that VM.
So if traffic isn't
getting to that VM,
is it because it can't
route to that VM?
Is it because there's
a firewall rule
that's blocking the traffic?
So again, from a traditional
networking standpoint of view,
you might use traceroute
and say, "Oh, I
see it went from
the original server.
It went to the router.
From the router, it
went to the firewall.
And then, I see it stop.
Oh, well, it's the firewall
that's blocking it."
But what do you do when the
firewall, the routes, all
of this stuff live on the VM?
What is it that's
actually causing
the packet not to get there?
So that's where things like
Network Intelligence Center,
they help bridge that gap.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And I think it's key
to note that there
are tools and modes
of thinking that still
are applicable in this case.
You can always run a traceroute
even if your applications live
in the cloud, and we also have
tools in logging and monitoring
like Cloud Trace,
so I think it's just
understanding where to
map certain concepts
and how they translate
into the cloud.
But do you find most
companies, in general,
who operate in a
network-centric model are more
or less eager to adopt
this service-oriented model
of networking?
RYAN PRZBYL: Eager to adopt?
Like I said, I think,
depending on who you talk to,
it might be a yes,
it might be a no.
Again, having a traditional
network engineering background,
it's a little bit scary when
you start talking about,
"We're going to put a whole
bunch of sidecar envoy proxies
in there, and we're
going to start
talking about service meshes
and service discovery,
and we're going to start
abstracting the network, where
we're really just--
this service needs to
connect to another service.
We'll just push it
to the Envoy Proxy
and let the Envoy Proxy figure
out how to handle this."
So again, you're abstracting
the network away.
As a networking guy,
it's like, "Well,
are you abstracting
my job away?"
This is what I've been
dealing with for 20 years.
And the answer is ultimately no.
The network still exists.
But it's a fundamental
shift, like a mental shift,
that you're having to make
to adapt with the times.
So I think most people see
that is the path forward,
but on one level,
it seems simple.
You talk about like,
"Oh, we're going to talk
about service networking.
We're talking about
service meshes and service
discoveries."
And even if you decide to
break a monolithic app down
into microservice
and things like that,
it's easy to whiteboard
this stuff out sometimes.
Implementing it is a
total another ballgame.
If you want to see a
really good video on this,
if you go to the
Envoy Proxy website,
Matt Klein over at Lyft
did a history of Lyft
and how they integrated a
lot of these level constructs
into Lyft's environment.
And it is a great--
trying to get your
hand or heads--
or getting your head around
a monolithic app being broken
to these smaller
services and really
what service networking
really looks like and all
the complexities around it.
It's probably an
hour-long watch,
but I thought Matt did a
really good job of describing
like, "Hey, this seems
easy on one hand,
but in reality, it is
a lot more complex."
So to your point, this
is why these very large,
traditional enterprises--
I think they see
that path forward,
but it's super scary when you
start watching videos like that
and you start dissecting
this and say, "I've got
to move 5,000 applications."
And if somebody wants
to use this model,
there's all this
complexity that's
going to get added to things
and things I have to solve for.
And, oh, by the
way, this is a way
of thinking that I maybe
never had to have in the past.
So I think a lot of
people see the vision,
but again, implementing it is
totally different ball game.
And that's where it
becomes incumbent on having
all those networking constructs
to make it easy and path
of least resistance
to move into the cloud
for a large enterprise.
And I call this a Grow
with Google Model.
So while we have a
lot of people that
are hyped on the service
architecture model,
it's like the Grand Canyon.
I can't expect somebody to
leap across the Grand Canyon.
I have to get them
into the environment,
and then, I have to build
these small stepping stones.
I have to start
introducing things
like PSC, like I
mentioned, like using it
to maybe front-end Google APIs.
Introduce it as a
small stepping stone
so that they can take
these small steps to get
across the Grand
Canyon and aren't
trying to make this
fundamental leap from "Here's
where I am today"
to "Here's where
Google sees us in the future."
STEPHANIE WONG: But
I mean, you're right.
It's growing with Google, and
I think we're continuously
investing in providing
those stepping stones that
better translate and map to
traditional networking models.
Meanwhile, customers
are also becoming
more accustomed to
adopting and taking
on the approach of
service-oriented models
with the emergence of
their newer applications
that are cloud-native.
RYAN PRZBYL: Yeah.
In what I mentioned
in the first video
too, there's the
technology aspect of it,
how to implement the technology,
but then there's the,
how does the
organization operate?
I can build a lot
of things in Google,
and we build tons of different
network architectures
with our customers.
But at some point, I
have to hand it over
to an operations team,
and the only thing
I can ever guarantee about
any network that I build
is it will break at some point.
That's just the one guarantee
I'm willing to make.
So it's not just a matter
of take the technology
and implement technology,
but it's also--
like I was mentioning in
the previous conversation--
thinking about how you
operationalize this stuff.
Like, what operational
impacts does it
have to your existing monitoring
suite, the existing tools
you use, the existing
processes, the existing mindset,
that a network
engineer goes through
to troubleshoot a problem?
If you're trying to abstract
more of the network away,
you've got to
think about, "Well,
how do I troubleshoot problems
when the service doesn't work?"
If I don't have
visibility to everything
and maybe I'm using some Google
tools that are new to me,
it's going to be a little bit
of a cultural shift, right?
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And you were just
talking about having
to overcome technical
debt, and we're
trying to provide a
path of least resistance
for our customers.
But what does that
begin to look like?
What is Google Cloud
doing in this space
to provide an easier path
or a lower barrier to entry?
RYAN PRZBYL: So again,
I think this goes back
to having the right
tools in the toolbox.
And to me, tools are
features and capabilities
at a networking layer.
So the path of least
resistance, ideally, is,
"I'm going to take
my data center,
and I'm going to forklift it
in the entire same way that
operates today in Google
Cloud with zero changes."
That would be the ideal, I
guess, path of least resistance
because literally
nothing changes.
The bottom line is that's
basically impossible.
You can't do it for
a number of reasons.
So when we're having those
conversations with customers,
we talk about, what
are the stepping stones
that a particular
customer can adopt
and that they can get
their head around using?
Even just the concept
of our basic-level VPC,
if you're talking
about a data center,
a data center is a
physical building
and a physical location.
And your network, when you start
to talk about the local area
network or in that data center,
maybe it's in Dallas, Texas,
as an example.
And then you move into cloud,
and you're like, "Well, now,
I have this construct
of a VPC, which
is like my data
center network, but it
can be a global construct.
OK, that's interesting.
Well, how do I set
up routing in there?
How do I do all this stuff?
Oh."
We tell people all
the time like, "You
don't have to do a lot
because our Andromeda SDN will
take care of a lot of things."
It's different from a
lot of our competitors,
where you're having to build a
lot of network infrastructure,
like VPNs or other things to
connect your region A to region
B. That starts to
look, in some ways,
like connecting
two data centers.
I've got to build a
network between them.
Then, you come to
Google, and it's like,
"Well, I can run stuff in Europe
and I can run stuff in APAC,
and they can seamlessly
talk together?"
Yeah.
"And you don't have
to build any network?"
Sure, we take care
of all that for you.
Again, we've abstracted
it under the hood.
So that's just an example of--
that, in itself, is a
fundamental difference.
You could build a VPC that
exists only in one region
and make it look and
feel like a data center,
but generally speaking,
I would advise a customer
not to do that.
So that would be one of
those stepping stones.
"Let's start thinking
about your network
as this global
construct that exists
in a different way than an
individual data center does."
So the more tools I
have in the toolbox--
and again, when I
say "tools," I'm
talking about product
features to say, OK,
you do things this way
today, and changing
that piece of your environment
is too difficult for you to do?
OK.
I want to be able
to let you move
that over apples to apples.
But this other piece
of the environment,
maybe we can move from
apples to oranges.
And this other piece
I can more drastically
change from apples to cherries.
That's what I do every day.
I am talking to customers
and figuring out
how do we move from here
to here but get some
of the advantages of cloud?
Even if we're talking about
just network-centric things.
We're not talking about any
of the service-oriented model.
Let's talk about what
your network looks
like two years out.
What do you want
it to look like,
and how do we help
you take it from where
it is today to where you want
it to be in two years, three
years, four years?
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And I think that
eases the concern
when you are looking at it
from the perspective of being
a partner over the span
of years, as opposed to,
we're asking you to make
an entire shift of model
and thinking in the span
of six months, but rather,
how can we get you to this new
world of service orientation
over the span of two to three
years, which is more, I think,
reasonable for people to accept.
And then I think
you've also mentioned
that you have a
viewpoint that Google
Cloud and other providers
should be providing
more traditional networking
tools or at least the ability
to translate what
you've been doing
in your current
environment into the cloud.
So when you say
these things, do you
mean offer more
customization, the ability
to control more of their routing
layers, things like that,
or is it more just about
tools in the toolbox?
RYAN PRZBYL: Yeah.
I mean, again,
when I say "tools,"
I'm talking about product
features and things like that.
So the one I mentioned
earlier with routing is,
let's say you do a whole bunch
with BGP-filtering policies
and things like that, or
you're using local pref
in a certain way
to drive routing.
That's not something we offer
today with our Cloud Router.
It's something I'm talking to
the Cloud Router team about
and saying like,
"Hey, what can we
do to offer more and more of
these basic-level features
that customers are using
within their data center
to manipulate routing?"
So those are the type
of things that I'm
talking about with the teams.
And when I say, "Offer these
tools or these products,"
the more of those I
have in the toolbox--
and I use that term
loosely, a "toolbox"--
it allows us, again, to create
that apple-to-apple sort
of scenario.
Now, the one thing that's
different that I do
want to talk about too is,
when you build a data center,
it's typically a very
capital-intensive thing.
You're going out
there, and you're
buying all this
equipment, and it's
very-- it's what we
call heavy CapEx model.
You can buy all these
routers and switches,
and they have a whole
list of features.
And you put them
in the data center,
and you use them for five years,
10 years, 15 years, whatever.
And then what happens is,
once they've lived their life,
you have another
big capital spend,
and you upgrade
that router and you
get a whole much more of
feature functionality out of it,
potentially.
This is the mindset
that people have done.
"I built the data
center day one,
and it's going to live
that way for the next five
years or 10 years.
I'm going to make small
incremental changes,
but I'm not going to make any
fundamental changes because I
spent all this
capital over here."
Cloud flips that
model on its head.
You're not buying
routers anymore.
It is a very OpEx-driven model.
So you're paying for these
services month over month.
You're not saying, "I have
this huge bucket of cash
I'm spending here.
And then 10 years
down the road, I'm
going to have to get another
huge bucket of cash."
So why is that important?
Well, in this OpEx
model, where you're
buying more managed
services-- like I was saying,
we're constantly introducing
new features and new tools
in the toolbox to
change the architecture
and to change the way
that you can do things.
So if you have this mentality
of, "I build it this way,
and then, it's going
to live for five years,
and I'm going to
change it," you're
not getting the full
advantage out of cloud.
The whole point of
cloud, in some ways,
is to be able to make
changes more periodically.
Even if-- again, go back to
the customer who yelled at me
and said, "It's very
difficult for us to do."
The more you can
adopt that mindset,
the more you can
capitalize on the evolution
that cloud is making.
We're launching new
features, and we're
giving you new capabilities.
You want to continuously
be integrating them,
not thinking like you do in a
traditional data center model,
where, "I got this model.
I'm going to change
it in five years."
It's like, I tell
customers every six months,
"You should be
looking at, what do
we need to change
in the architecture?
How do we roll this
architecture forward?"
But if you're taking those
incremental changes every six
months, it's much easier to
get to your two-year vision,
your five-year
vision versus maybe
that traditional mentality.
So again, I think people need
to think about cloud differently
just from that standpoint.
It's an OpEx model.
You're not spending CapEx,
which should make it easier
for you to be integrating these
changes over the course of time
versus making these
very large step function
changes to the way things
are running in the cloud
environment.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
I think you having
that background
in traditional
networking helps you
understand where a lot of these
customers are coming from.
And it is about
crawl, walk, and run.
But I do see that some
customers are probably
going to think, "OK,
well, I don't really
have a project that would
require me to be in the cloud
just yet because everything's
operating on premise."
But perhaps there is a team
that is the cloud disruptor
at the company, who might have
a test project or a test dev
environment that they want to
start operating in the cloud.
And so, thus, I think that
relationship between network
and the developers
or other teams
would be important in that case
to actually identify these use
cases, where you
can start adopting
these models in the cloud.
But I do--
RYAN PRZBYL: Yup.
STEPHANIE WONG: --want to
zoom out just a little bit
and talk about the future of
where this is all heading.
Where do you see cloud
networking heading?
I see that we're
getting to a point
where things are
converging with networking
and service-oriented models.
But what do you think is going
to be the future for cloud
and for Google
Cloud in this space?
RYAN PRZBYL: So
it's definitely--
as we've been orbiting around
this service networking model,
that is the future, hands down.
I don't see it being
anything other than this.
And again, just look
at how Google operates.
We operate services even though,
like I talked about earlier,
we run a very complex network.
At the end of the day,
we don't run a network
to run the network.
We run services.
The network is just part of it.
And you look at--
so as an example,
you look at how our
SRE teams operate.
We have SRE teams that
operate in these verticals.
So they operate this service.
This service has
networking as part of it,
but there's a lot
of other components,
and that's how our
SRE teams operate.
Now, we have a networking SRE
team that goes horizontally
across things, and
you're always going
to have to have some
level of expertise there.
But I see us as an
operating company
who are operating services.
We're building a structure
around these services
themselves.
And then, there's the stuff
that's wrapped around them
to support those
services, and that
includes networking and
all of the constructs
that exist in networking.
It will continue to
evolve to be more
of this service-oriented
construct
whether we like it or not.
And like you said, I can
empathize with customers
because there's some
level of uncomfortability,
if that's a word, but I get
very uncomfortable just trying
to learn all that stuff and
trying to get my head around it
because it's not my background.
I'm the traditional router guy
like, "Let's build the routes.
Let's do all this stuff.
Let's not--" the whole
concept of service discovery
and service meshes, I
get it at the surface.
But when you peel
back the onion,
you realize just
how complex it is.
And when you don't have 20
years of experience doing it,
it's very daunting.
So I think, to answer
your direct question, that
is the future.
20 years from now,
I think networking--
there'll be a lot more
managed services in play
that is obfuscating or managing
a lot of the networking.
And the network engineer
20 years from now
will probably be very different
than the network engineer who
works in the industry today.
So if you're a young
network engineer
and you're just
getting started, you
want to start digesting
all of that stuff
because that's going to be
very commonplace in 10 years.
Hopefully, at that
point, maybe I'm retired,
and I don't have
to worry about it.
But that is where
things are going.
This is the whole point of
having these conversations.
Three years ago, I wasn't
Now--
STEPHANIE WONG: Yes.
RYAN PRZBYL: --more and
more of the conversations
are like this
service-oriented construct
and what is Google
offering here.
What is Google's
vision of the future?
And it really is
all of these things.
Is traditional networking ever
going to completely go away?
Absolutely not.
It's always going to be there.
Routers still exist,
and routes still
exist to move bits and
bytes back and forth.
It's just a matter
of how they're built
and the constructs that we're
using over the top that,
I think, change.
And you start to be less focused
on the network and start--
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
RYAN PRZBYL: --focusing more
on the services themselves.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right.
Well, thank you so
much again, Ryan,
for covering this somewhat
less talked about topic.
You have an important job in the
coming years to help customers
move to and adopt this
service-oriented model
in the cloud--
at least before you're retired--
and at the same
time, you want to be
able to support more of a
traditional network-oriented
model, whether
it's lift and shift
or conversion into the cloud.
So I just want to thank you
again for being on the show,
and thank everybody else for
joining and for tuning in.
RYAN PRZBYL: Yeah.
And I'd love-- for people
that are watching this,
was this interesting to
hear for us to talk about?
What are some other topics
you'd like to see us talk about?
I have things I think are
great and interesting,
but I'd love to hear
from people that
are out there in the world.
And I'm happy to
look at your comments
and brainstorm about
how we can deliver
some more content to you.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, exactly.
So if there's anything
we covered today
that was of interest or we
didn't get to a question
that you might have about this
topic, please comment below.
We are actually going
to read all of them
and respond to all
of your comments.
Thank you so much,
everyone, for joining,
and check out our next
episodes coming out.
Thanks for tuning in.
RYAN PRZBYL: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]